so we're going to talk a little bit
about bohr and then we're going to talk
about ionization energy which is a theme
that's going to come back
a couple more times very important
and then we're going quantum
we're going quantum and that's why this
is a very exciting day
uh for me and i i'm hoping it will be
for you too
it's why i have t-shirts it's also a
goody bag day there's just all sorts of
things
happening today so i'm very excited
this is how we ended our lecture on
wednesday
okay i was showing you this as part of
my why this matters which started with
refrigerators
and then we talked about a chemistry
problem cfcs
and we talked about how those were
destroying the ozone layer of this
planet
now why is that important and i had this
picture up there
to help explain it this is
just to to make sure we all see what
this is you know i'm
showing it here again this is the energy
watts per meter squared
that we get from the sun right and
and you can measure that up on top of
the atmosphere so there's no atmosphere
there
and this is what it looks like right
that's the energy
as a function of the wavelength or
frequency
or energy of the photon you now know how
to go back and forth between those
but see on the planet here once you once
you
have the atmosphere you get a different
spectrum and the reason is and it's
shown here that
some of the molecules in the atmosphere
are absorbing
parts of that spectrum so what we see on
the planet is different
right and we talk about this in terms of
why this matters
and and how ozone you know so you say
well i said i mentioned oh if you could
only if we could only see out here
right the visible is here that's the
visible okay there's the
frequencies of the visible but what if
it were here the planet would be totally
dark
because no light would get through the
absorption that happens from
those molecules on the other hand over
here we've got ozone that's protecting
us
it is absorbing light in the higher
frequency in the higher frequency
which means lower wavelength that's the
uv
and that's why that was such an
important problem is to not destroy
those precious ozone molecules
okay so i want to make sure that we and
we understood this in terms of
energy transitions because how do these
things absorb light
well they do just what we said which is
they take the energy from
a kind of light and and an electron then
takes that energy absorbs it to be
excited and it goes from one energy
level
to another right we did that in terms of
the board levels
so i want to do that and that is what
you have right here
right you have a way to see that visible
spectrum so we'll talk about that
as well oh we'll talk about it right now
because i have a slide on it
so you have what is known as
a spectroscope or the most powerful way
to see light
ever designed and and if you look
through this
okay don't look at the uv please don't
look at the sun
with this please don't do that but we
gave you
light sources to look at like that right
or
you could look at that or you could look
at like things around you with it
and what are you seeing you're seeing
this you're seeing the spectrum
in the visible you're seeing it in this
part okay
but from this you are also what you are
seeing
are literally electron transitions you
are literally
and that's what i want you to think
about that's why i wanted you to have
this power
this power which means responsibility as
we know but
now you can not only see light you can
see electron transitions
i want you to think about that as you're
seeing light
and and i want you to think about it in
terms of what we learned on wednesday
which is bore
right and so let's let's just put that
here
okay so we had bohr and
in the bohr model we said the energy
is going to be quantized minus 13.6
electron volts times the atomic number
squared divided by n squared
right and so like for hydrogen
for example this is equal to uh minus
13.6 ev
right because z is one over n squared so
that was our
for hydrogen z equals
one all right and so that that's one and
that's it
but n is equal to one two
three etc it's quantized right this was
this was the whole uh kind of discussion
and theme of wednesday's lecture
and and and that got us to these levels
these bore levels which are places where
energetic places energies of the
electron
right so we'd have these levels
that kept on going until you're at
somehow
right so if this is energy
right and and this would be like n
equals one
n equals two these are the energies
right right there i'm just plugging in
and this would be like n equals infinity
so the energy here
would be zero and for the hydrogen atom
the energy here would be minus 13.6
electron volts right if that's hydrogen
so this is
now i'm leaving this here i want to use
this that's why i'm putting it back up
okay because look now you can use this
to start
understanding light and so you use this
and you look at light sources
and you can start thinking about things
in terms of energy transitions so let's
take a look so what if i
uh just look at some light sources right
okay so that's what you see that's like
the sun
right so that's daylight and now we're
getting into the the mode of seeing
light like this right it's in intensity
salute versus uh wavelength right
and there you go you go and now if you
look at sort of an incandescent light
bulb
all right it'll look something like this
so it's it's warm
there's a little more red right you
can't get up to the sun's temperature
but you get pretty hot
so you see this nice kind of looking
spectrum and oh here's a halogen
all right that looks kind of closer
maybe look at what happens when we go
fluorescent ah
look at that why does fluorescent light
give us headaches
well that might be other reasons but but
look at this spectrum
that doesn't look like that that's why
we all have so much trouble with floor
and here's leds and you can buy your
cool white leds and your warm white leds
but look
they're still not they're not that right
there's been a lot of work on this
can we get this to be that right
and and so so now we are armed
with with great power
and so you can look at things you see oh
i see that it has
uh this large peak because i'm looking
at a fluorescent light
within and i see that it's got this
stronger peak in the blue
maybe i could just absorb a little of
that what if i came up with a coating
right that i could put on that cool led
bulb to make it just a little bit more
look like that
well now we know how to we might be able
to use bore to do this
right because because what if i say okay
the
the wavelength of that is around 450.
so if the wavelength is 450 nanometers
then i know you know remember we did
this
waves right light waves we can go back
and forth
between uh frequency below
how's it going all right welcome to
class um
and uh and energy energy
equals h c over lambda
oh plank thank you
and this is roughly 2.75
electron volts for that wavelength
2.75 electron volts right okay well but
see now
but i want to absorb some of those
photons
i'll pose a problem what if i have
an atom so question right
so i have an atom an atom
that has
an n equal 4 to n
equal 5 transition
that absorbs so i'm i'm telling you now
this energy so i'm telling you now
i've got some atom and i know there's a
transition in it
it has an electron transition because
remember we're going from electron
transitions to light energy back and
forth back but this right here
i'm just saying look okay n equal just
keep going n equals three
n equals four n equals five so what i
just asked you is i said well look
some atom has
a transition between n equals four and
equals five that means that
if an electron happens to be here it can
absorb
energy to promote it up to here of
exactly 2.75 ev
well i can use bore i can use bore now
right because
so i can actually answer this problem
answer this question if i know that
then i can say well okay if the initial
state is
four and the final state is five right
i've gone from four to five i've
promoted an electron
up in energy lifting it up like a ball
against gravity
all right then if then i can use boar to
say that 2.75
ev is equal to minus 13.6
z squared times 1 over 5
squared minus 1 over 4 squared
that would be the transition energy this
dictated by bohr and oh i have
everything except z
which i can solve for z equals three
z equals three all right so so i've now
all i need to do is come up with a way
to coat all the cool
leds with lithium right
because this is lithium
and we'll be fine except there's a
problem and this is part of the problem
that we need to address and solve today
before the weekend and that is that
see bohr only works
war only works for one electron now it's
okay z can be higher
z is three and it works here but i've
assumed only one
electron which means this really would
be like li-2 plus
okay we're going to come back to that
but bohr
only for
one electron
right so so if i'm going to get
something like like z
is three that's fine but it can only
have one electron there
can only have one electron there or the
model doesn't work it was one electron
with some z of protons right
so this could be li-2 plus that sounds
harder
to put into a film okay
we will be coming back to this that is a
serious limitation
of the bohr model and we can't do a lot
if we can only do one electron
right you do a lot of ions
but that's it okay
so i just said the word ion
what happens now if
you take an electron not from one level
up in energy but up up up up up all the
way until it's free
what happens if you do that well that is
called ionization
that's ionization and in fact when you
look out into the beautiful world
the universe remember i said on
wednesday 75
of this is hydrogen a whole lot of it is
ionized it's getting ionized
from energy that's that's knocking
electrons out and then electrons are
coming back
and cascading through these levels
emitting discrete
frequencies of light and this is what
you see it's beautiful
right what you're looking at is ionized
hydrogen
getting electrons coming in and
cascading through the bore levels
right ah but what does ionized hydrogen
mean
right okay we can now understand it
we can now understand it because now
instead of going from like four to five
i'm going from anything to infinity it's
like escape velocity right
it's like how much velocity do i need to
give something so it just gets away
from the earth and it's not going to
feel the earth's
gravitational pull well here i don't
want this electron to
feel the potential of the atom anymore
the z the positive charge i want it to
just be free
that's here that's infinity that's n
equals infinity
right so if if i think about this
that that's actually quite easy to put
into bohr ionization
energy so
to save time we'll write ie right
and this is equal to the energy
required oh i'm going to save time here
look at that requida
to remove
the electron from the atom
okay good and and if we think about this
in terms of bore
it would be like minus 13.6
let's say for hydrogen because i've got
hydrogen up there so for hydrogen
meaning z equals 1 it'd be minus 13.6
times 1
squared that's the z squared right
times 1 over
nf squared minus 1 over
n i squared that's that delta e which
equals minus 13.6
times 1 over infinity
minus 1 over n i squared
right now the last i checked with my
colleagues in the math department that's
zero
that's zero right so the ionization
energy
you literally can just read off here if
an electron is in the ground
state if there's a happy electron right
here in this orbital
the amount of energy i need to input
into that atom
to knock the electron fully out the
ionization energy
is 13.6 electron volts right it's just
the energy of that orbital
i could get a little fancier i could say
well
okay what about this question
what if i had light with a hundred
nanometers
so now i'm telling you my source right
before i didn't tell you
something goes into it and knocks it all
out no now i know what's going in
the the uh the wavelength or the energy
of the photons is a hundred nanometers
and i'm shining that on hydrogen well
now okay let's see here so let's stop oh
i'm asking a question what's the
question what is the lowest energy level
that the electron could be in such that
a photon from this light source
ionizes the atom okay let's see
because i now i now know the pieces and
i know the definition
right so now if i have the energy
of a hundred nanometer photon
well that i'm not going to go through it
is equal to 12.4 ev
but see if i now want to use this to
ionize hydrogen
then i get something like this i get
that delta e
equals minus 13.6
okay times
uh one over infinity squared okay fine
we'll keep that for a sec
minus one over n i squared right
this is how much this is how much uh uh
delta
i need to ionize from any given place
any
given energy level and i right
okay but but i have 12. so what if i set
this equal to 12
right if i set this equal to 12.4 that's
what i have
then what i get is n i
equals 1.05
okay good that's my answer
no panic everybody should be panicking
no that can't be my answer
i can't i can't have something that's
not an integer
because i said it over there that n is a
quantum number
one two three nothing is allowed in
between
so what you can see is that i got so
close
i almost had enough energy to get n to
b1 but i don't
so i cannot use this light to ionize an
electron
in n equals one i can't but i could use
it to ionize an electron in n equals two
right because there if n is two
well then i've got actually plenty of
energy
right so
cannot ionize
from n i equals one
but n i equals two
is okay right so that's the outcome of
this
now i could also use that same 12.4 ev
photon
to ionize from n equals three or four or
any of these
but i can't get to one and there's one
other concept that's important because
look
i gave it 12.4 ev
what did i actually need well i mean you
can even see it here
you can just you know what these levels
are from the bohr model
here this is 13.6 this is
minus 3.4 okay that's telling me this is
definitely not drawn to scale
but still you you get the point 3.4
and and i just said well i could
probably get it out of 3.4 and i can
because i've got 12.4
and so if i did this so if n
i equals two then i would have excess
energy
excess energy would be nine electron
volts
and that is kinetic right so i've shot
this thing out of the atom
with light that's got way more energy
than i needed to ionize it but that
energy didn't it's still in the electron
i transferred that photon energy to the
electron energy
and so that is going to be
in the kinetic energy of
the electron that's now free the
electron free
i should have said free electron right
excess kinetic energy comes after
ionizing it right so these things
are the things we can do with bohr so i
wanted to kind of
you know take what we learned wednesday
and apply it to a few problems
and go back and forth with
with this idea of photon energy uh
to bore level changes and that's what i
want you to do in
this week's goodie bag as well okay
now ionization is an important concept
like i said we'll be coming back to it
um and you can you can actually uh
plot and many people have measured and
and this is very important
the ionization energy of elements like
as a function of
atomic number and the first ionization
energy
is important right the first ionization
energy is the energy
required to remove the outermost
electron right
right so if i did have a whole bunch of
of electrons so if i had
a whole bunch of electrons the first
ionization the first
ionization energy is the energy
required
to remove the outermost one
so that's an important number to know if
you want to take an electron off of an
atom
and we will be doing that because that's
how we're going to make our first
bond next week if you want to take an
electron off an atom this is one of the
first things you ask
how much energy does it take right how
much energy does it take so that's an
important concept that we'll be coming
back to now
okay i alluded to the fact that we
needed a new theory
i already alluded to that and i said
that's where we're going today
the bohr model works for one electron as
i said all right that means it's good
for hydrogen
oh we just ionized hydrogen that was a
lot of fun
and it's good for like he plus
or li2 plus or osmium 75 plus
yeah that's real but what about two
electrons
what about two just two forget about ten
twenty thirty
two the bohr model can't do it it
doesn't
it it doesn't work for anything more
than one electron it was derived for one
electron and that's where it stays so
we're at this point now
this is a picture i started to draw this
week on monday and we're at a point
where we need something deeper
and some of the work that went into this
was really critical
and i'm not going to go into too much
detail but there's one thing i want you
to know so remember
you know plank and einstein they were
playing with quantization of light
and einstein's photoelectric effect
found the particle nature of light
with planks you know with together their
energy
right equals h nu that quantized energy
of the photon
and they they saw it's a particle but it
also is is a
is a wave right there's a lot of
discussion and
and interest and and attempts to
understand
what it was was it a wave or a particle
and compton did some beautiful
experiments to show again
evidence that it was a particle because
he he saw how
light interacted with electrons and it
was like this collision
that particles do and then de broglie
or as where's jerome de bruyne
i don't know would say he went
further de broglie went further he said
everything is both light you guys don't
know if light is a particle or wave well
i'm saying everything is a wave
everything and everything has this
duality
so he wrote something very important
which is
the relationship between anything's
momentum
and it's wavelength so we'll come back
to this so i want to write it down so
de brush he said
that the wavelength of anything can be
written
as oh that same quantization number
constant from planck divided by its
momentum
literally just its momentum anything has
a wave nature
anything and light has a particle nature
what's going on
and it led einstein to say at the time
he said quote it seems as though we must
use sometimes the one theory and
sometimes the other
while at times we may use either we are
faced with a new kind of difficulty we
have two contradictory pictures of
reality
separately neither of them fully
explains the phenomena of light
but together they do this was the
beginning
of quantum mechanics this is where they
were
and and later once they once they really
got the quantum mechanics kind of going
he said this the more success the
quantum mechanics has the sillier it
looks
why well there's only one way
uh to really learn about quantum
especially if it's the first time and
that's from dr quantum himself
and so i do have a video of dr quanum
and i'm hoping you will enjoy this with
me i enjoy it every time i see it
most friday nights um so
let's watch dr quantum explain
because there was one really important
experiment
that happened that he's going to explain
right now called the double slit
experiment and it changed everything
and i don't care if you see it in
another class we're seeing it here
because this sets up
what happens next in chemistry let's
watch dr quantum
we are the granddaddy of all quantum
weirdness
the infamous double slit experiment
to understand this experiment we first
need to see
how particles or little balls of matter
act if we randomly shoot a small
object say a marble at the screen
we see a pattern on the back wall where
they went through the slit
and hit now if we add a second slit
we would expect to see a second band
duplicated
to the right
now let's look at waves
the waves hit the slit and radiate out
striking the back wall with the most
intensity
directly in line with the slit
the line of brightness on the back
screen shows that intensity
this is similar to the line the marbles
make
but when we add the second slit
something different happens if the top
of one wave
meets the bottom of another wave
they cancel each other out so now
there is an interference pattern on the
back wall
places where the two tops meet are the
highest intensity
the bright lines and where they cancel
there is nothing
so when we throw things
that is matter through two slits
we get this two bands of hits
and with waves we get an interference
pattern
of many bands good
so far now let's go
quantum my favorite line i love that
line
an electron is a tiny tiny bit
of matter like a tiny marble
let's fire a stream through one slit
it behaves just like the marble a single
band
so if we shoot these tiny bits through
two slits we should get like the marbles
two bands what
an interference pattern we fired
electrons tiny bits of matter through
but we get a pattern like waves not like
little marbles
how how could pieces of matter
create an interference pattern like a
wave
it doesn't make sense but
physicists are clever they thought maybe
those little balls are bouncing off each
other
and creating that pattern so
they decide to shoot electrons through
one at a time
there is no way they can interfere with
each other
but after an hour of this the same
interference pattern is seen to emerge
the conclusion is inescapable the single
electron
leaves as a particle becomes a wave of
potentials
goes through both slits and interferes
with itself to hit the wall like a
particle
but mathematically it's even stranger it
goes through both slits
and it goes through neither and it goes
through just one
and it goes through just the other all
of these possibilities
are in superposition with each other but
physicists were completely baffled by
this
so they decided to peek and see which
slit
it actually goes through
they put a measuring device by one slip
to see which one it went through
and let it fly
but the quantum world is far more
mysterious than they could have imagined
when they observed the electron went
back
to behaving like a little marble it
produced a pattern of two
bands not an interference pattern of
many
the very act of measuring
or observing which slit it went through
meant it only went through one not both
the electron decided to act
differently though it was aware
it was being watched and it was here
that physicists stepped forever into the
strange
never world of quantum events
what is matter marbles or waves
and waves of what and what does an
observer have to do with
any of this the observer
collapsed the wave function
[Music]
simply by observing
you you can see why i show this uh we do
movie night at home a lot
it's friday night guys like seriously um
you know
that uh you know you might have like a
little free time
you get together with some friends
there's no better way but look
let me you know this is why i hope
that's as mind-blowing to you as it is
to me it was mind-blowing to them
at the time um this led border famously
say
anyone who is not shocked by quantum
theory has not understood it
and and here's the thing there's uh
you know there are some things in life
where you can ask questions and and you
can understand them you can answer them
i can ask the question why do or
somebody might say
why do i wear a a t-shirt under a sport
coat
that's weird stylistically
i mean stylistically that's and i say
well okay here's the answer
because i put you know comfort over
stylistic norms whatever
that's an answer i could ask a harder
question
i could ask a harder question why did
justin and celina break up
because jelena was totally hashtag
couple goals
just saying okay anyway now i'm just
why oh but still that's a harder
question
why because they were so good but
there's probably an answer to that too
that's a harder question
this was mind-blowing how can something
be both how can something that they know
is a part of how can everything
be both this was really
difficult to answer and in fact
the real answer came with a mathematical
solution
which we'll learn next but not quite
understanding
we still don't really understand quantum
mechanics even after 100 years
we don't um and
and so so this is just i think a
beautiful part of
our story of our detective story
and just to show like people are still
working on this right
how much quantum can we see how much
quantum can we see
well look here's some here's somebody
who
about 15 years ago and it's published in
this paper i'm a little more almost 20
now
they actually took forget about
electrons those are teeny tiny things
this is a whole group of of 60 carbon
atoms that's called a fullerene
and they shot this through they did the
double slit experiment with this
and they showed that with the grating
right without you get the single p
just like we saw and with you get
diffract you get interference
you get interference so they were able
to show all the way up to
a large molecule 60 carbon atoms
that these things are still they have
wavelength they have these
these incredibly strange properties that
you just saw
in the double slit experiment all
everything has
this duality this this duality between
uh waves and particles
now um okay
we said we needed a new model right bohr
can only do one electron
and meanwhile there's all this stuff
going on at the time
you know showing that that there you
need a new theory
how do we explain waves and to kind of
put a little bit more of of the nail in
the coffin for for bore
you had um you had heisenberg so i'll
just
write this on the board before i go to
my why this matters
um and what heisenberg said
is that you cannot
measure
both
position and
momentum exactly
you can't get them both okay and that
that
that's called the heisenberg uncertainty
principle but that was it because look
you look at that so he he's saying this
and said but
in board you've got them both you've got
them both exactly
remember we i put energy down there but
we also put r
on wednesday exactly because then type
you can't get them both
and if you can't get them both that's
another problem with bohr because bohr
says you can get them exactly right
so we had these pointers double sid
experiment heisenberg's theories
right saying we need something more we
need something more
and i'll i'll get to that um i want to
do my why this matters and then i'll get
to
the more that came which will then
expand on on monday
um before i do that let's do wise
matters so why
why are why is the fact that an electron
is a wave why is that so
important first of all because it sets
up
you know this this detective story of
the electron
set up this new theory that's coming
quantum mechanics right
um but also it immediately just like
just like we started painting with them
right remember that was one of my widest
matters we also realized that we could
see
with them we could see with electrons
because you know if electrons are waves
then i can shine them just like i shine
light and see what it shows me
right it can illuminate matter
so you know if you look at the frequency
here
of light right this is this is a
electromagnetic spectrum
radio right microwave infrared visible
uv now here's the thing
if you want to see something
some feature size you're limited
by the wavelength of the light it can't
be
bigger than the features you're looking
at roughly ish
okay that's what you're so if you're
trying to see something tiny but the
wavelength of light is really big
you won't see it so we need if we want
let's say we want to see atoms
let's say we want to see atoms or or or
even more nuclei
look at how tight those are 10 to the
minus 10 centimeters 12 meters
those are x-rays or gamma rays but the
problem is if we shine
x-rays on things and we will do that
when we look at crystals
but if we shine x-rays it's very hard to
then collect them and make a
photographic image
okay right i mean at least one that gets
you that resolution
and gamma rays are even harder to catch
right
oh but see here's the thing electrons
electrons give you exactly what you need
because you know if we do this math
for an electron let's bring this one
back down
if we do this math for an electron well
i'm going to use
ah i thought i had the middle one so if
i have an electron let's suppose i have
an electron
that is
electron i'm going to say i accelerate
it
over 100 volts
i'm going to take an electron i'm going
to put it over 100 volts i'm going to
give it some kinetic energy
right so its kinetic energy
is then going to equal 100 ev right
okay so now i've got an electron moving
with a kinetic energy that's 100 ev now
you can convert this to joules and you
can
set this equal to one-half mv squared
right
mass of the electron times its velocity
squared and
then once you have the velocity so you
get the v
and then once you have that you get the
momentum
the p right and then once you have that
you get the wavelength right so i can go
now from like
something that's easy to do 100 volts is
a lot but
in a lab safe not in your dorm you could
apply 100 volts
to an electron get it going at this
speed
and once you know the speed you know the
momentum and if you know mv
then you know it's wavelength and that
in that case
from this relationship you would get
that it's about 0.12
nanometers but look at this the
wavelength of a
simply accelerated electron is right
where i need it
it's right where i need it it's an
angstrom
right so now i think if i take advantage
of the wavelengths of the wave nature of
electrons and i shine them
on materials then i can see materials
that way and i can see them at that
scale and we do that all the time
all the time in in many many different
areas of technology
and of research today we use electrons
to image in fact the best images you can
get
are made with electrons right here's an
example
of using scanning what's called a
scanning electron microscope
right so you see a butterfly but you
want to really see a butterfly
or we can go even further and instead of
just drawing pictures
of this these beautiful materials made
of carbon those are called nanotubes
these are called this is called graphene
because in tight
it's a single sheet of carbon atoms one
atom thick material notice with these
materials
every single atom is a surface atom
that's pretty cool
they also have lots of other cool
properties and i'll give you examples
throughout you know in other other
lectures of how these kinds of materials
can be used
but for now i'm talking about seeing
them and this is what happens
when you actually look at them with an
electron that's a nanotube and here
is a picture of graphene the only reason
we can see graphene
is because we have electrons and we take
advantage of the wave nature
of those electrons we say well okay but
why does that matter
well that matters tremendously because
one of the first experiments
that really did what feynman what
richard feynman wanted
richard feynman predicted the the field
of nanotechnology
50 years ago he gave a famous speech at
caltech it's called there's plenty of
room at the bottom
he's also an amazing teacher and he
taught actually the double slit
experiment i highly recommend you
googling that lecture and he said that
you know someday you can put the atom
where you want
right and the first time that was done
was in 1989 by ibm
they had 35 xenon atoms they moved them
around the point is you couldn't realize
nanotechnology you couldn't
realize the ability to actually move
atoms if you can't see them
right and so this you know the ability
to see
what you were doing changed everything
it changed everything and you know
nature had been doing this and i love
these examples so you know nature has
been doing nanotech for a long time
right uh so you have uh the inner ear of
the frog it's a cantilever that uh
sensitive to a few nanometers of
movement the frog can actually hear that
you've got features in the ant's eye i
love the the silk moth
the male silk moth has a single
molecule detection system on board
that can sense a single molecule
pheromone it can detect a female silk
moth two miles away
two miles away we have nothing like that
we have no technologies like that i
can't even tell if someone's in the next
room
i have to look at my phone or something
this is because of nanotechnology
that kind of detection system right but
it was the ability to see
atoms and molecules with electrons that
that kind of blew open this entire field
right and it's made it so that we can
now try at least to rival nature
here's one example you're not just
seeing graphene but check this out
you're seeing a single atom of graphene
and you're seeing what happens
under a certain kind of ra irradiation
and you're seeing this hole
and you're seeing the whole grow and
that's really important because
something i care a lot about our
membranes
right and another why this matters i'll
tell you about membranes but here
you know i'm actually making the
thinnest possible membrane that
that you could make because it's only
one atom thick and i'm controlling
how i make that but i would never know
what my controls do if i couldn't see it
in real time right so this is this is my
my why this matters it's seeing things
at this scale
okay so back to so there's heisenberg
right so at every moment
the electron is only inaccurate position
and inaccurate velocity this was
again saying bohr you got to think
harder
um and we had all of this these
experiments showing the
the the particle wave duality of nature
and of
of atoms um and so the question then
became
all these pointers from all these
different places the question became
how do we describe these this wave
nature
of matter how do we describe an electron
as a wave and i like this
because not only do i think if
schrodinger had a swimming pool
this is what he would do with it but
also i thought maybe this would be cool
for like an mit
kind of swim test thing um in the future
because you can see what happens
um this just i i want to do this
experiment
um but this looks really fun they're
making waves they're
they're literally making waves right um
but and so the question now look at that
see but the question is how do you
describe it well there are wave
equations
there are wave equations that we know
about
that relate the position of a wave to
its time change and velocity
right and and the thing is this is it
this is how we need to describe an
electron
now think about it for a second an
electron
by the way it just occurred to me that
you should take this on that same date
because
if they don't have real candles and they
only have these
you should have this handy because you
might need to pull it out and see what
kind of led
they gave you what does it look like
anyway
okay that was a side point
bohr says electrons can only be in
certain places
well that's mind-blowing because but by
the way think about that
an electron can only be here here oh by
the way it can transition between them
but it can never be
between them did anyone catch that
what's up with that it can't be between
them i am
telling you that but it can transition
where did it go
oh okay that's a weekend kind of
thinking exercise
and now we're saying they're not even
they're not even like
in one place they're waves
they're like the water
that's cra that that really was at the
time they thought how is this possible
right but schrodinger came along and he
said i'm gonna write down the equation
anyway
and and that's that was the the
the big contribution the the really
critical contribution that schroedinger
did
is he said i'm gonna i'm gonna write
down
kind of like a newton's equation like an
f equals ma but for
for quantum mechanics and for waves like
electrons
and i'm going to describe them so he
developed the equation
that we solved that on monday we'll
solve to describe the wave nature
of quantum mechanics and and just to
to end so on on monday we'll pick up
with schrodinger's equation
for the atom you know the question is
what does this all mean for chemistry
what does this mean
we're not i'm not teaching you quantum
i'm not teaching you quantum just so you
know quantum in isolation i'm telling
you about it
because it completely revolutionized
chemistry and and that is where we will
answer that question
on monday have a really good weekend
you